this has been my dream
this is a franchise that I love so much
and I wanted to come in and bring
something to it please get off my car
my friends and family are truly freaking
out over this
they finally think I'm cool
nothing's impossible
just have to have a little faith that
moment when Finn took the cross eyes
just the most surreal moments of my life
and I just fell over remember that was
too iconic I'm sorry I did not know that
you were gonna do that oh
a fan of
them there was no recovering from that I
could not be cool it's one of those
iconic props in film history and I
couldn't believe I was being entrusted
with it it felt powerful it just is so
trippy I mean Vin Diesel carried me like
what that was on my bingo card for my
whole life and it happened to me
right let's try